[Música]
el comité del congreso que investiga el
asalto al capitolio de 2021 en eeuu
celebró la que sería la última audiencia
pública en la que buscó demostrar que
donald trump no hizo nada por parar las
violentas movilizaciones de esa jornada
se espera que el informe final sea
entregado en otoño
el presidente chileno gabriel boric
lanzó una nueva campaña que busca
incentivar la votación para el
plebiscito que determinará si se aprueba
la nueva constitución esto en medio de
las afirmaciones de la oposición que
reitera que el mandatario está
interviniendo en el proceso electoral lo
que está prohibido
la fiscalía de perú abrió una cuarta
investigación preliminar contra el
presidente pedro castillo el caso se
presenta por un presunto delito contra
la administración de justicia y
encubrimiento en relación con la
destitución del ex ministro del
interior- mariano gonzález
bienvenidos a esta emisión con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano soy valentina torres sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos empezamos en
eeuu el comité del congreso que
investiga el asalto al capitolio del 6
de enero de 2021 celebró la que sería su
última audiencia pública la comisión
busca demostrar que donald trump no hizo
nada por parar las violentas protestas
de esa jornada se espera que en otoño el
comité entregue su informe en el que
podría emitir recomendaciones penales al
departamento de justicia dejando en
manos del fiscal general merrick garland
la decisión de si trump otros deberían
ser procesados
hemos confirmado en numerosas
entrevistas con altos líderes policiales
y militares con el vicepresidente pence
su personal y funcionarios del gobierno
que ninguno de ellos escuchó al
presidente de trump ese día no llamó
para dar órdenes no llamó para ofrecer
asistencia health affairs state en chile
siguen las polémicas en torno al
plebiscito en el que la ciudadanía
decidirá si adopta la nueva constitución
redactada por la convención
constitucional y que reemplazaría a la
heredado de la dictadura de augusto
pinochet
el presidente chileno gabriel boric
lanzó una nueva campaña que busca
incentivar la votación lo que para la
oposición es interferencia el informe es
de manuel acá no
por un voto informado el presidente
gabriel boric lanzó una estrategia que
busca sensibilizar a la ciudadanía sobre
el plebiscito de septiembre en el que
los chilenos decidirán si adoptan o no
la nueva constitución los invito a que
todos enfrentemos juntos un debate con
altura de mira no permitamos que las
mentiras se impongan acá hemos escuchado
muchas veces cosas que no tienen que ver
con la realidad y por eso es importante
que la gente conozca el texto
pero la campaña despertó polémica pues
llega un día después de que el
presidente publicará en su instagram un
contenido que hacía referencia al voto
por la aprobación del texto redactado
por la convención constituyente
a pesar de que el mensaje fue borrado la
oposición cuestionó que el mandatario
esté haciendo campaña algo que está
prohibido el presidente de boris
regalando y autografiando libros de la
propuesta constitucional e impresos por
el gobierno haciendo campaña con la
plata de todos los chilenos una
intervención burda y la contraloría no
hace absolutamente nada los expertos
recalcan que a pesar de que existe una
sintonía ideológica entre el gobierno y
la convención constituyente en la que
76% de sus miembros son de izquierda del
centro estando debería derivar en la
participación en el proceso electoral
por parte del presidente la visión del
mundo
de la conversión es bastante afín a la a
la de la administración actual pero no
tiene medio para intervenir y si iba a
estar vigilado por el parlamento por los
medios de comunicación por la propia
contraloría y por lo cual estaba
obligado a mantener una un nivel de
neutralidad la oposición ya había pedido
investigar los motivos de una reunión
con los coordinadores de la campaña de
la prueba en el palacio de la moneda
unas acusaciones que no prosperaron
en otras noticias la fiscalía general de
perú abrió una nueva investigación
preliminar contra el presidente pedro
castillo un día después de que el ex
ministro del interior lo acusara de
obstruir las investigaciones de
corrupción de sus aliados cercanos el
jefe de estado del país andino que lleva
poco menos de un año en el cargo se
encuentra en una posición cada vez más
precaria con bajos índices de aprobación
y escándalos en su círculo íntimo
mariana villacorta nos trae la historia
es la cuarta investigación preliminar
que la fiscalía de perú abre contra el
presidente pedro castillo esta vez por
presunto delito contra la administración
de justicia y encubrimiento personal
algo que el mandatario desestima
nosotros no tenemos tiempo para
entretenernos en otras cosas nosotros no
estamos acá para hacer un circo el país
nos ha puesto para trabajar por el perú
el martes el jefe de estado del país
inca destituyó por sorpresa mariano
gonzález ministro del interior durante
15 días horas después de su despido
acusó al mandatario de estar
comprometido con actos de corrupción
la justicia esto porque según gonzález
su destitución se produjo luego de
autorizar el nombramiento de una unidad
policial especial destinada a localizar
y arrestar a los aliados del presidente
que estén bajo investigación penal como
el ex ministro de transportes juan silva
el ex secretario de palacio bruno
pacheco y un sobrino del mandatario fray
vásquez lo que recibí
fue un reclamo natural
porque él es porque no estaba de acuerdo
con mi decisión
no es que me haya dicho el presiente en
algún momento no capturé a los prófugos
pero lo que me cuestionaba era la
decisión de ir por ellos las otras tres
investigaciones que castillo tiene
abiertas son una por presuntos delitos
de organización criminal y tráfico de
influencias en torno a contrataciones
ilícitas en el ministerio de transporte
y comunicaciones otra por supuestas
irregularidades en ascensos en miembros
de las fuerzas armadas y de la policía y
otra en relación al presunto plagio de
su tesis doctoral
asimismo ha sobrevivido a dos intentos
de destitución y algunos legisladores
piden un tercer juicio político por las
nuevas acusaciones el partido de los
trabajadores de brasil oficializó la
candidatura de la presidencia del ex
jefe de estado luiz inácio 'lula' da
silva quien intentará conquistar un
tercer mandato lula llamó a derrotar en
las urnas al presidente ya ir bolsonaro
quien aspira a la reelección para poder
recuperar la democracia en esta nación
suramericana el informe es de rafael
pérez
lula va oficialmente por la presidencia
de brasil
el anuncio se dio a conocer en una
convención de la cúpula del partido de
los trabajadores y partidos de coalición
progresistas en la cita también se
aprobó la fórmula vicepresidencial del
candidato de izquierda el liberal
geraldo alckim el país está
experimentando una completa degradación
en todos los aspectos de la vida
nacional en nuestra campaña que decimos
hoy encabezada por lula y al king
es una pieza fundamental para encaminar
al país para traer la garantía de la
institucionalidad democrática a nuestro
país
lula no asistió al evento pero se
manifestó en las redes sociales no
necesitaba volver a ser presidente
podría mantener mi título como el mejor
presidente de la historia e ir a vivir
los últimos años de mi vida en paz pero
vi este país destruido vi la educación
dirigida por un tipo al que no le gusta
la educación así que decidí volver la
mayoría de los sondeos dan como vencedor
al líder sindical frente al actual
mandatario ya ir bolsonaro esta es la
sexta ocasión que lula se lanza en busca
de la presidencia del gigante
suramericano logrando establecerse en el
palacio de planalto en dos ocasiones el
líder de la izquierda francesa jean luc
mélenchon llegó a colombia para reunirse
con el presidente de electo gustavo
petro me lanzó estuvo de visita por
méxico y honduras y busca acercarse a la
izquierda latinoamericana en medio del
auge en el continente luís muñoz
periodista de france 24 no se ampliaba
previamente esta información
a escasos metros de donde nos
encontramos en el norte de bogotá la
capital de colombia ha habido una
reunión privada entre el presidente
electo de colombia gustavo petro y el
líder de la oposición de izquierda
francesa jean-luc mélenchon que ha
venido a una gira latinoamericana en una
primera parada en méxico donde se reunió
con andrés manuel lópez obrador después
continuó por honduras con xiomara castró
la presidenta y ha terminado aquí en
colombia dice que ha venido para
aprender sin ninguna intención de dar
ninguna lección ya que piensa que la
izquierda en europa está totalmente
destruida y es latinoamericana la que
puede inspirar claramente es gustavo
petro el más adelantado en el
pensamiento es decir la reformulación
del marco de izquierda dentro del marco
del desafío del cambio climático
como una fuente de innovación de
inversión
de cambio de la manera producir
intercambiar etcétera precisamente
después de reunirse con gustavo petro ha
dicho que se lleva muchos aprendizajes y
sobre todo piensa que gustavo petro es
el líder latinoamericano de izquierda
más avanzado así llegamos al final de
esta emisión de noticias les agradecemos
su sintonía continúan con nosotros que
volvemos en breve
[Música]